okay thank you i'm a professor in civil
and environmental engineering
a background in chemical engineering
and i think a lot about water
this friday i'll be giving a talk at
homecoming weekend
and so i thought maybe i could try this
talk out on you all
and see how it might play in coverley
auditorium at 3
30 on friday so the title of this uh
talk is uh got water you know that's
like the milk mustache thing you know
and the theme is urban water supplies in
the arid west
and the subject that i'll be
discussing is informed by that paper
that i sent earlier
and by our group of researchers faculty
graduate students post docs and others
that are participating in a
nsf engineering research center
of which i'm the director and the title
of that center
is reinventing the nation's urban water
infrastructure
the center comprises stanford berkeley
colorado school of mines and new mexico
state
so when i go through here i'll i'll show
examples that
um relate to the work in our center and
i don't claim to you know i'm not
the person who does all this but
obviously i'm involved
so what is it that we think about in
terms of urban water
uh and in the west
one is that we have a population
increase
if we were in wisconsin or somewhere
there might be population decrease
or some parts of the midwest
we have people moving to what you might
call the dry sun belt
we also have climate change and up
through
uh july of this year was the driest year
on record
on record in much of the west
and we see that climate change will mean
we'll be hotter and drier
and our precipitation will come
more as rain than snow and that that
presents challenges for us
like all of our nation's infrastructure
there's gap in
maintaining it and
with our water infrastructure most of it
is between
50 and 100 years old so one way or
another it's at the end of its service
life
so they're going to be lots of
investments in urban water
infrastructure
and what we can do now is look at the
current system
as it needs to meet these challenges
and think about are there new ways of
doing business and can we do something
different in the future to save money
save water and save energy
and part of the vision for the future is
we want to rely on less imported water
and also we recognize there's new water
contaminants that we have to pay
attention to as well
so how is it that we address all of
these challenges then
the way we think about it is maybe we
could work
in four areas uh one is
increasing water availability that would
mean
like thinking for example of more water
reuse or maybe storm water as our source
of our drinking water supply
another one is in broadening our
treatment options
and i show here a picture of a wetland
and doing new kinds of treatment
and looking at the role that natural
systems might play as part of our
physical infrastructure
a third is considering waste water not
as a waste but as a resource
for energy and in certain nutrients
and then this one uh which is important
uh is sort of the systems level thinking
and integration
we're dealing with public infrastructure
and public systems
so naturally there's a planning
social political and economic process
that takes place
in in the area in which we work and we
have to be able to address
those institutional issues where nothing
will change
in other words we could have students
doing the very best work in these three
boxes
but if we don't understand how things
are integrate
at the systems level and how to address
those
scale up issues the regulatory issues
the planning issues and life cycle
analysis
then we're just stuck and
what i mean by stuck is we'll have
published papers and students
like hannah will graduate but we won't
have an impact
so let's look at some examples here and
i'm going to just show you
uh examples from a few examples from
california
and then one from colorado so this
is a picture of where we get our water
from
in santa clara valley it's a pie chart
and obviously and
the pie chart shows where we are today
there's a lot of imported water here
this uh central valley is imported water
it's pumped in state water project is
pumped in and there's a little wedge up
there called recycling
now the goal is to more than double
the amount of water that we're recycling
in the next 10 years
in other words that wedge is going to
get bigger
so how well are we doing at that and
there's a picture here that
shows the current situation
the wastewater for san jose milpitas
santa clara
goes down to one base big wastewater
treatment plant
it's off 237 the south end of the bay
and if you
when you fly into sfo you kind of turn
and if you look out the window you can
see this
this big plant well it does a very good
job of
of treating wastewater and so water
flows
downhill to the centralized facility
then it goes
through a few additional steps and then
it's
it's recycled and it's redistributed
through these kinds of systems here
that's a pipe
and it's got a characteristic color
purple and that identifies it as
recycled water
and that's uh it's just what's done for
code
all right so we have the centralized
facility
and pumping back to the cities and that
water can go around in a loop
the thing that's interesting about this
is when we look at these
energy that's required to deliver this
water there's a lot of benefits that
come from recycling water
so there are a number of little bars
here but the one i want to point to are
the ones with these
red arrows this is the energy content
and you can forget about the units here
but just look at the height of that bar
that's the current water supply for
santa clara valley this much of it this
big green part
that's the pumping of the water to the
system
from the state water project and the
like
if we go to recycled water
we can we're not paying for that big
import fee
that energy fee i guess and we've
reduced the energy content by about half
so this is a good idea
but but even here there's a fair amount
of
energy that's required to distribute
that water
in this system so how's this system
looking today then
there's a little bit of a problem when
you have the centralized facility
at the edge of the bay you have these
big sewer interceptors all coming
down to the treatment plant and we're
talking about big flows here like
100 a million gallons a day or so
you have this big flow coming down to
the treatment plant
with these sewers and the sewers will
tend to infiltrate
a bit in other words water tend to leak
in and that water is a little bit
brackish
because you're near the edge of the bay
the end result is because of the salt
content on the imported water
and the salt that leaks in the water is
a little bit too salty
to expand the
reuse of that water so what the
city has built is a 10 million gallon a
day facility
to try out uh ways to remove those salts
now
just think of sodium chloride because
we're not talking big contaminants here
just simple salts
the additional steps are a series of
nanofiltration
reverse osmosis and uv disinfection
basically when we're all done with that
we produce something that's essentially
drinking water
and the idea here now is we re-blend
that
in that recycled water you have
something like distilled water
with this salty water you mix the two
together and average it out you get the
salt content that you want
so even with this treatment this is
still less
than imported water even though you have
to provide this extra
energy here so that's the situation
today but the question is is can we do
better than that
and the answer is well if we had to
redesign the system we might
rethink the idea of these centralized
plants so that star up there is the
central plant
and these these lines here are that 130
miles of that
distribution system the reverse plumbing
system
now what's expensive here
is putting in those purple pipes if you
have to dig up streets in a city
you're on the order about two million
dollars a mile
or so to put that those pipes in place
also in this case
uh you're basically taking water
from where it was used and generating it
letting it flow all downhill treating it
to a high degree
and then pumping it all back uphill
so one one vision of rethinking our
systems here
was that maybe we should imagine
our future water supply and wastewater
systems
being more distributed than centralized
and how might this work um
well this would be example of what you
might call a
a sewer shed kind of like a tree where
different communities are sending water
to a centralized facility
and let's imagine this box up there in
the up right corner is stanford campus
we could imagine building a wastewater
reclamation facility right here on the
stanford campus over by
uh well behind the credit union if you
know where that is off bonaire siding
where all the dump trucks are
demonstrate how we could reclaim
water that would be suitable for
irrigation on the stanford caps
demonstrate how this can be done with
energy recovery
so it's energy neutral or maybe energy
positive
and from a pilot experiment or that
something that would be on the scale of
maybe 10 or 20 gallons a minute
then we could use that as a test bed to
say would this vision really be realized
could we actually expand this
out and treat the million gallons a day
of wastewater that comes from the
stanford campus
so the idea here is this kind of a
system
would provide several benefits not only
does it
allow us to meet our future water supply
needs on the stanford campus
but we would also have a system that
we're recovering energy
and we're being able to do this water
recycle in a much more efficient mode
and this is what we have in in planning
to actually demonstrate on the stanford
campus over there
at a pilot facility that's
that's in design right now to test out
technologies that would allow us to
achieve this vision
when we look at stanford it's sort of
obvious in a way that maybe we would
make a good
sub area for study or for trial
because we're you know we're kind of
self-contained and all the sewers on
campus go to one place and that would be
the place you'd want to tap in
but when we look at the problem here
this is just this is the sewer shed for
the palo alto
uh water quality control plant and
when you begin to think well how's this
really going to work in practice
you end up with lots of issues to
discuss here that
are like well what's the spatial
configuration what's the topography
oh what's the hydraulic models what's
the flow on mass balance
what kind of systems would you put in a
satellite treatment plant
uh you have all kinds of technologies to
choose from would you do energy recovery
or not
what's the resilience of the system well
you could ask you could put more issues
here but you can see right away
how you'll get so many common
combinations and permutations that
if you really want to think this out it
becomes a complicated problem
and we've been using uh
decision analytic tools coupled to uh
technology modules
to address the issue of what would be
the right vision
for for this system and the vision would
be a couple of satellite plants and
still the centralized facility though
doing something a little bit different
in the future
so thinking through this then how the
how does that
vision of that satellite treatment plant
work it's kind of tricky to say where
where exactly and and how and so this is
our first test case at that
the other thing is is when we look at
these purple pipe systems
we're producing here uh typically
one water quality all the time
and we can do better than that you'd
think maybe i should be able to produce
waters of different quality depending on
what its
intended use is and we can for
inspiration on this we can
look down at a treatment facility that's
south of the
los angeles international airport
and at west basin this is if you go
south of the la airport there's a big
industrial area
kind of along the coast there it's
petroleum refineries and whatnot
but what they do there at that treatment
plant is they produce waters of five
different qualities
now depending on if it's using for
cooling potable reuse
irrigation and whatnot
so it's possible to do this
but it's not possible to extend this
vision very far from what it is now
today
because they've already exploited their
customer base
right there in that small district where
all those
in that sort of industrial area of la
so we were thinking in the center here
then well
how do we produce waters of different
quality and what quality might we like
and this is a system that's being tested
at colorado school of mines
it's basically a combination of membrane
reactors and biological treatment
systems
that can produce water is largely of two
quality
that's safe to come in contact with but
one
if you operate the system one way you
leave nitrogen and phosphorus in the
water
if you operate another way you take it
out
now what's what's about nitrogen and
phosphorus so these are nutrients
so if you're using water for irrigation
as you would in the summer you might
want to operate this plant
to lead the nutrients in because it'll
supply a little bit of the nitrogen and
phosphorus
but in the winter time when the ground's
frozen
uh this water would go to a stream and
you don't want to over fertilize streams
and rivers
so you take the take the nutrients out
well this idea of being able to switch
back and forth between waters of two
qualities nutrient rich or nutrient poor
is an example of tailored water and has
a this this
that switch right there is one that has
a lot of implications to expand water
reuse
the other one is i mentioned in that
in that box of sort of four themes was
the one of wastewater as a resource
wastewater contains organic matter it
contains nitrogen as well ammonia
and what we do today is we expend
energy to treat that wastewater
but the waste water itself if you look
at the chemical energy that's in there
in terms of reduced carbon and reduced
nitrogen
it has more than enough
chemical potential energy to treat
itself but how do we do that
well we have to go to a new kinds of
systems we need to
go to anaerobic technologies that
there's technologies that don't involve
aeration and capture all of this carbon
is methane
and then we can combust the methane
produce electricity
and these plants can become energy
positive and that's a different mode of
operation
but to take a big plant like east bay
municipal utility district and say all
right let's
get rid of all your aeration basins
we're going to go to this new
idea well we have to test these out at
scale
at some scale and again this is
something we could test out at
the stanford modules that we would place
over on the other corner of campus
another thing that's interesting here is
to think about wastewater treatment
plants of the future
as resource recovery facilities
my folks moved to palo alto in december
of 56
and at that time in the summer in august
the bay lands would stink like you can't
imagine
the stink and where was it coming from
it was coming from san jose and from all
the canning operations that were done
down in san jose now there are no
canneries left there anymore
uh so with the canneries canning
facilities moving
away and the upgrading the treatment
plants we weren't discharging this waste
to the bay
there used to be canneries in oakland
too but they're not there anymore
but the plant was designed when they
were expecting a lot of you know
food processing waste to come to the
plants so in oakland they happen to have
excess capacity in these systems here
that are called
digesters so what what
they've done at east bay municipal
utility district is
to rethink one part of their operations
and that's this part that deals with all
the waste sludges
and have instituted a program
to bring in trucked food waste from napa
and the central valley like chicken
blood or whatever
and then process through these digesters
and convert that carbonaceous material
of methane
and then combust that and that's a
successful program
and now east bay municipal utility
district's plant
is really the first energy positive
plant
wastewater treatment plant in the
country and they're able to do this
because of the trucked waste program
so for us in our center here what we're
studying are these uh
anaerobic technologies how they'll
really work
and then also the business model of the
trucked waste i mean what if napa
decides
you know this looks like a good deal why
don't we instead of having the trucks
run down to
oakland why don't we why don't we do
this ourselves or what if
modesto decides you know this is a great
idea we can just do that too
how many of these facilities could you
support around the bay well those are
the kinds of
sort of systems level questions that
that come to mind about
expanding this now so there's sort of a
business finance issues here
and there are these technological issues
about how you really make these plants
work
reliably um
the other box that i mentioned at the
start of the talk was the
broadening the treatment options and
here
we might think of how can we use natural
systems to treat our water
and natural systems you can think of as
wetlands or maybe these bioinfiltration
basins like this
and you've all seen these along
curbsides and the like
well we believe natural systems can
improve our water quality
they can be a source of local water for
us
obviously they prove the urban
aesthetics and they create habitat
so when we think about reuse and storm
water capture
and recharge of groundwater there's a
big role here for natural systems to
play a role
these natural systems i would think you
all
have seen wetlands and marshes and
grassy areas and you think
gee that's there's a peel
do you like the wildlife habitat the
purification the low energy the green
but you know engineers look at this and
maybe plant operators look at these and
say you know
these natural systems are unpredictable
they may be inefficient if it gets cold
there's some seasonal variability i
really don't know how to manage to
optimize or change performance
so these are issues that
we're addressing in our center is how
can we better
invoke natural systems as part of our
urban water infrastructure
now where might this go well let's look
at the issue of storm water capture
you all know storm water you know what
happens around here with
all our storm water we just collect it
up and push it to the bay as fast as we
can
and you you know all the curves that say
you know don't throw the waste here
flows to bay
so all along all the big cities you know
kind of like from
well the california coast here the the
the mentality was uh quickly collect
that storm water and shove it to the
ocean or bay
and get rid of it now we see it as a
resource for the future
so this is a another pie chart the last
pie chart i'll show
is where the city of la sees them
getting their water for the future
this is where they are today and that's
where they want to go tomorrow
and so they're two pie charts but this
doesn't look like much of a pie chart
because there's one big huge piece here
and this is the piece that's water
imported from northern california in the
colorado river
and the plan for the future 20 years out
is even with increase in population
the absolute amount of water that
they're going to import
is going to be less and this is a trend
for the future
less reliance on imported water and so
how do you make up this difference
well recycled water plays a big role
and storm water capture now plays a big
role i mean it was storm water wasn't
even on the
on the on on this side of the picture
so how does storm water capture really
work how would it work in la
well um
uh we live in a mediterranean climate
and what does that mean that means we
get these heavy rain storms in the
winter
and then it doesn't rain for six months
or something like that or whatever
you know we're still in our dry season
so we have a challenge here of sort of
balancing out
the time when we have water and the time
when we need it
our approach to these flashy storms was
to build these things that you see in
hollywood movies
you know the chase scenes and terminator
or something
and then another problem here is that
you get these big
surges that's kind of flush the city and
you end up with contaminated beaches
and there's some parts of the city north
of the burbank airport that don't even
have storm sewers
so that's where we are here so we say
well how can we
think of a of a
new way of sort of managing this flashy
systems manage the localized flooding
save this water before it goes to the
ocean
and at the same time prevent the
pollution
of beaches now that's the idea
well
how big would these systems have to be
to make a difference
well this shows the cost
per acre foot of water captured versus
the acre feet captured in other words
you say
cost per gallon versus number of gallons
and an acre foot is about a third of a
million gallons
the point here is you can
see how this this is these are both log
scales
so to be efficient here we need a big
system
we need something that will capture
about a thousand acre feet a year
and that becomes an efficient size
well um where where might we
try this out and we're working with the
city of los angeles
well the la department of water and
power and the bureau of sanitation
and public works to
look at a field site north of the
burbank airport
which is a current old gravel pit
and a little bit of a dump for
construction debris
and converting that to a system that
would collect storm water hold it for a
while
then process it through this wetland and
thereby purify the water we might have
to put a few more steps here
and then pump it about that far
into the ground and becomes part of the
water supply
for the city of los angeles now that's
the picture
this is the artist picture i have other
ones that make this look like
it's just this little isolated thing out
in the green space you know
the reality is though this is the area
in which it sits
uh a lot of automobile recycling and
industrial activity just just off the
edge of the picture here
so when we think about storm water
capture we need a we need a big spot
and you can repurpose some of these
sorts of places
but you also need to be aware that storm
water is
not clean obviously it contains
biocides uh you know that are used for
weed control
and that kind of things uh it has uh
vehicle-related contaminants uh oils and
stuff like that additives to tires
ingredients and anti-freeze all of this
is is in our storm water so
the challenge for us then is to think
about
how do these how might that wetland
system really work
and removing those those kinds of
contaminants
and these are not those those ones i
just had on the
previous slide are not the normal thing
you find in wastewater this is storm
water
and so what we're looking at here is a
combination of both
natural systems like a cell here that
would be open
and a system like this that might have
an infiltration system with different
media to remove the last little bit of
contaminants
so the idea is that we are imagining
that we can do a better job of man of
designing and operating
these wetland systems and
here i show a picture of a of a wetland
system that really doesn't have any
plants
in it at least emergent plants it's a
very shallow system
about a foot and a half deep and the
idea here is to put
is to promote a reaction with sunlight
that's called photolysis
and then in this system you'd be growing
a little bit of algae
and there'd be some bacteria there so
there's a combination of
a physiochemical transformation here
by reaction with sunlight and then
bacterial reactions here in this in this
bottom little uh layer that would form
in that cell
and we've we've tested these ideas out
at that
picture i just showed earlier at uh at
this small plant up here in discovery
bay
but there are questions about how does
this really scale up and will it be
reliable at big scale
and for that we are working with orange
county water district
and they have just built for our testing
a set of three parallel cells that are
100 feet wide each and 800 feet long
and so this is a this is
i guess you'd almost i call this a
full-scale system
but we have these three parallel trains
here or we could make it be serpentine
back and forth
that system is built and our
experimentation
will begin later this year on
addressing questions of both uh
sort of a biogeochemical nature and a
control
how do we actually sense and control
these facilities
so um i guess i go a little bit off
script here a little bit you know this
shows the
value that this water district has
placed in our
and our ideas here when you look at
we look at this i have another picture
that maybe i should use that on friday
it shows a truck
out there and you can't see the truck i
mean you can tell this is a dump truck
and this thing is huge uh so
anyway this is right by the santa ana
river and
and this will be our experimental
facility to look at
at how to upscale
these these new ideas and
wetland treatment systems another
area in which we're working is out near
denver
sort of northwest of the denver airport
this is the south platte river that
flows out of denver and the south platte
river in the summertime
and much of the year is basically
wastewater from denver i mean
it's been treated but it's what's
referred to as an
effluent dominated river
with some water transactions there was
an opportunity for the city of aurora
to take some of this water and pump it
to meet their water needs
and what they've set up here and what
we've studied and investigated
over the last several years is the how
this system works
in terms of this pumping of the water
from the river
now you don't pump it from the river
directly you pump it
from this well that's adjacent to the
river so you get a little bit it's
called bank filtration you get a little
bit of filtration
to the earth here that water then goes
into this recharge basin
stays in there for a while and is pumped
out and then goes to the city
so it's a combination of a bank
filtration and this recharge basin
and this leads to a new idea that we've
been able to show
about how different reactions
are occurring in each parts of these
system
to remove contaminants when you pump the
water
through the ground or into the ground
and then you're going to pump it out
again
it comes with a little bit of
contaminants
they're more degradable they deplete the
oxygen in the water
so in this first step here you get a
consortium of microbes
that can live on sort of the easily
degraded
substances that are in that water and
then they begin to deplete the oxygen
you pump that over into this system
there's a picture of the aurora
recharge basin you pump it over here and
you get a different floor of microbes
and what happens there now is the easily
degraded carbon is gone
it's an oxygen system and you get a
whole different floor of microbes
the two together really remove the trace
contaminants with a high degree of
efficiency
so we call this managed
aquifer recharge or because we're at
stanford i guess we like to put an i
before everything
i might call it i mar but that's a
this understanding these these working
together these two
systems has led to
better understanding of how we can
recharge groundwater in ways in which
they can become part of our urban water
supply
but do it in ways that are safely or
that are safe
and then lastly the last box i talked
about
was the one of the establishing the
enabling environment
meaning how do you do systems level
thinking
you know what's the why should i do
storm water versus
water recycle or why do i need to do
either of those
can i just buy someone else's water you
know say when you think about your urban
water supply
well for this there's no straight answer
there's no one answer for
every place they're clearly
regional and political realities and the
solutions that come up in one place
are not the same for another place
but within one region i think we can
understand that
working to working together collectively
can provide local benefits
with that thought this is a picture of
sonoma county and we're working with
sonoma county water agency
to look at the idea of stormwater
capture for them
now they've gone through a whole lot of
review with their
citizens in sonoma and have said
and then through a bunch of public
meetings and
presentations i guess like this they get
informed about the future of their water
supply what do you people want
what did the public want
and there were two things flood
prevention
and storm water capture for reuse
now this comes from a you know sort of
large decision analysis but down to
those two things flood prevention
and storm water reuse so
what's our contribution here well we're
going to be looking again at some
contaminant removal in those systems
but another big picture idea is where
exactly would you put these capture
systems
where do they fit in terms of an urban
planning context what does it mean to
repurpose some land
would the community accept that
how many times could you replicate it
how many sites could there be
that you would work at so for this
this takes us into the realm of urban
planning and design
we meaning folks like me and my
colleagues can come up with these
systems that remove contaminants
and collect the water now you say well
where do i place them
out here well you can imagine that's a
whole different set of questions
another issue in the bay area that we're
facing this is the last example
is the role of nitrogen
in in san francisco bay nitrogen's in
wastewater
it's a uh the nitrogen and wastewater is
really no different than the nitrogen
and fertilizer
you put fertilizer on the ground and the
grass grows
you put fertilizer in the bay and then
what happens
who said that you did algae
today yes some years ago no
because the bay was more turbid
so remember if algae needs nutrients and
need sunlight when the bay was more
turbid this nitrogen discharge was not
there were controls on nitrogen but it
wasn't such a big issue
now with the bay becoming clearer
because of
less silt input from the old mining
activities a long time ago
and invasive clams that sit at the
bottom of the bay and act as filter
feeders
the water is getting clearer so
we now are facing a
issue about nitrogen removal from all
these wastewaters
this and then how might you do this well
man this is a billion dollar pro all the
problems here are b
pro billion dollar problems you have
a bunch of wastewater dischargers that
now think oh gosh i got to do nitrogen
removal before it was
don't discharge ammonia because that's
toxic to fish but you can convert the
ammonia to something else
well how might you do this would you go
up here in the north end of the bay
storm water is a big deal in the south
end of the bay it's
wastewater treatment plants what what
system might you look at to say how am i
going to deal with this
and one area that we're looking at is to
go back and revisit
this wetland treatment system again and
we're working with uh
um oroloma which is over by you know
just north of union city
and are talking about a way in which we
could take their waste water
put it in a dyke system
and that waste water you know which is
basically clean but has nitrate in it
would flow through the subsurface and in
this
process here the nitrates taken out and
the water steeps to the bay
now what's special here
well this is a low energy system
you're building up a dike here that
gives you some flood protection
this might work 50 60 years something
like that
it creates a habitat where there isn't
now
and there's also recreational benefits
that can occur you know with bicycle
paths around
this kind of facility and you can
imagine this
expanding perhaps around the south end
of the bay
this piece here this fresh water this
brackish water ecosystem this this reach
is largely gone
on the fringe of the bay because of fill
all right last slide now is say well how
do you
how do you put all this together do you
like this or not how are you going to
manage nitrogen
and this is where you all come in you
you know you say let's look at a
decision tree here
a decision tree i mean you know a little
decision matrix
we can do various things as engineers i
could go optimize my plant that's get
down there and
tweak the daylights out of it so that it
works the very best it can
i can also upgrade a plant put moo
more technology inside the plant fence
or i might try this thing at oroloma
that's
being designed and built use wetland
systems
or i might think of water reuse if i
reuse water i'm not putting nitrogen
nutrients back in the bay or i might
think about source control
in various ways and then you can look at
this
diagram and think okay
what's the cost what's the risk of
failure and that's a huge thing in our
field
you don't want to fail what are the
institutional barriers
what kind of co-benefits are there
are there opportunities for additional
funding beyond a wastewater treatment
group and would be public support
for those ideas well
what we're looking at in our center here
is this idea that
maybe we could solve this
help solve the problem by paying more
attention to the role of wetlands and
and water reuse at the end of the day
it's going to be a ho all of these
things are going to be
all of these will be done but for us in
our research we think we can contribute
here
and what i'd like to do is take some of
these boxes that are orange or yellow
and turn them green and that's the role
of our research
the example would be say risk of failure
uh to show that well we can actually
operate
that system in oroloma reliably to
remove nitrate for example
and that box would go uh from orange to
yellow
or maybe green in time
so to sum up then
what's the urban water of the in the
future going to look like
for us in california in the arid west
these are these are the big points here
more locally sourced water
that means less imports
making do with the waste water and
recycle it
and capturing storm water we'll think
more about these decentralized systems
as part of our infrastructure now
we see storm water reuse we look at
systems that
are in which we can recover energy
wastewater treatment with resource
recovery
right now when we when i showed you that
picture of that san jose plant and i
said it produces essentially
tap water that really is tap water but
right now it gets blended back into that
recycled water
probably what will happen in the future
is as we learn about that system
and how it operates there'll be
something that'll be another decision
made you know maybe we should put that
in a lake or in the ground because it's
so good water
why blend it with that recycled water
for irrigation
so there's some combination there
between a direct or direct portable
reuse
but we'll see more of that and this
integration of natural and engineered
systems
all in the context of urban planning
social science and systems uh
systems level view so
that's all i wanted to say i'd be happy
to answer any questions now
we're all done
yeah listen start with students
um so i know that uh among the different
options that you
you sort of showed a bar graph of the
energy intensity of different water
sources
uh um desalination was sort of the most
energy intensive
option but i know that it's being done
in the middle east and also in
australia pretty heavily and there's a
new plant going in or being proposed in
san diego
do you see saltwater desalination as a
viable option in the future or
playing a big piece of the pie the
question was about
the desalination its role in the future
it does have a role in the future but
it won't be the same everywhere this ros
this system i showed you for san jose
that's a that's basically a desal system
the situation in israel and much of the
middle east is there's really no other
water around
so they're forced to look at the ocean
when i i showed you the pie chart for
los angeles remember all those little
wedges there
you'll note that desal is not on not one
of those wedges
there's water reused there's storm water
captured but this is not ocean desail
and why is that that's because the
community in la has decided that
ocean water desalination for their water
supply is too energy intensive
it's not sustainable it produces a brine
that might harm
the coastal ecosystem so they've decided
we're not going to do it
and it wasn't on the pie chart and
that's a kind of a good question to ask
if we had more time is what's missing
here
on that one san diego they're at the end
of the pipeline so to speak on all this
distribution system and their
their options are less so they're
building
this big ocean desal plant in carlsbad
which is the largest uh
seawater reclamation plant in the
western hemisphere
australia went through the millennium
drought 10 years of drought
and all the big cities there perth
sydney
adelaide melbourne
i'm missing one there's five brisbane
all the big cities put in these desal
plants
no sooner had those been built then
i got some heavy rains so
what's happened in australia now
is because of the crisis they said we
need to build
big desalination plants but now
they're not operating
so they're very intermittent but you
have to pay the capital costs
so this to me is a little lesson in
what happens when you get into a crisis
and about
these big public investments i'm not
saying the details wrong perth needs it
that's for them uh but you might think
well maybe we built these plants too big
we could have done something better with
better
systems management of our whole water
supply so
in australia there's a little bit of
head scratching then about
we're paying a lot for those plants but
they're not running
so it's different and i guess my own
view
here is that we don't have to work with
seawater you have salts and waste water
you have brackish water
um work with that and the energy that's
required
to take the salts out is directly
proportional to salt content
so that's why water reviews make so much
sense or water of impaired quality think
of it that way
brackish water that's say one-third or
one-fifth seawater or something on that
order
oh yes improve the efficiency of these
d-cell plants in terms of using this
energy
well the basically
there's been a whole lot of engineering
tweaks
over the years and there were
advances in membrane technologies that
reduced the pressure requirement across
the membranes
and then there was big advancements in
energy recovery
basically you have to pressurize water
to a high degree
to force it through these little thin
membranes
and you end up with a reject stream
that's more salty but it's at high
pressure
and through smart engineering you say
well i have high pressure water i can
run some turbines off of that
and so that energy recovery
has that that played a big role in
improving
these energy efficiency of these desal
plants and maybe they're
how much is it three and a half well the
units are just
a little odd here but it's
but there's been no high risk high
reward type
research in in diesel
yes it's been uh
yeah yes that's right it's been
incremental when they
came to these very thin polyamide
membranes uh
that was a breakthrough you know i was
20 some years ago or 30 years ago
and the other one was in all these pumps
and when you have a high pressure stream
however capture the energy out of it
yeah
basically it's the we are living
with systems that we knew about say two
decades
two decades ago but have made them more
energy efficient and more reliable
rve has not had any real interest in
this area rbe
rpe right
arc and department of energy oh i'm
sorry i
didn't understand what you're were
not directly you know
we in our field look very much at
you know the sort of that uh energy
that's in water
that's kind of our perspective and
that's an important wedge but maybe a
few percent
it was something that would show up on a
pie chart but this is a small wedge
the the water required to make energy
now that's a different one
you know that's where you have all the
big cooling towers and you may have
the frac water and that kind of stuff so
i think the doe
or rpg is more interested in the water
to make energy
ours is the energy in water
can do project in the flow competition
yeah so i'm interested in the energy to
you know
creating energy out of water you were
down in l.a for
caltech for that no i was here but i
youni
i helped him in that competition wow
yeah um
all right let's step back for a second i
gotta give a talk like this to the alums
you know uh
we touched on a lot of things here and
one of them is like
energy positive treatment
how does that really work well i don't
think i can put up a bunch of slides
with
some ammonia going to nitrous oxide
putting that down in a combustor and
no i try to want to
oxide is communicate rocket fuel and
stuff because i think people
visually have an idea of what kind of
force yeah maybe i can go back to that
and say
capture ammonia that was the uh
when we looked at yeah this is like
you know how do we deal with a nitrogen
problem in the bay
another one is is if you go to a
complete anaerobic system
for this energy recovery of the carbon
you know with a whole lot of ammonia
and there are ways and this is what
we've researched here at stanford is to
take that ammonia
and make it make it to nitrous oxide and
you can blend that in with the methane
and you get an energy boost
it acts as a you know it takes the place
of oxygen
and the combustion process
yes last year you hit more on those
chemical pathways and
i i it seems like you've got time
that that is a fascinating thing to add
okay i can put that in there and i'll
say
you have there are different ways to uh
address this so maybe i can say
with climate change a little bit more
especially for this class are
interested you know what can you say
about
um cities coastal communities worrying
about rising sea levels about
more severe storms about variability of
when it's going to rain or when it isn't
so
dealing with floods and droughts with
much more frequency
things like that are just of keen
interest right
and really important well that's exactly
the problem you have
uh is the variability in our water
uh and you know we have wet years and
dry years
with greater decentralization and more
reuse you're kind of bulletproofing
yourself against that right
right there i guess there are lots of
ways to think about it but
you want to think about the resiliency
of your system
and water reuse
is a good assured water supply
storm water capture is making use of
water that's currently available but
we're not using it
so those things have you know think oh
gosh we should be doing that
to a larger and larger degree and that
means we're less dependent
on the water imports and the water
imports are hugely affected by climate
change
and that's water from the sierra nevadas
the snow melt
or from the colorado river
so the future here is there's a lot of
challenges about how we manage those
systems
and historically it's been the tension
between agriculture and cities
who gets the water but there's a third
claimant now
i was in school when the clean um
uh water act was passed and basically it
said you couldn't kill the fish you know
with your waste but there was nothing in
that act that said you couldn't take all
their water
you know that's yeah now we realize we
can't take all the water
so we need to provide more water for
ecosystem services
in other words the san joaquin needs to
flow
and right now it's you know the water
you have these diversions and there are
places where it doesn't flow in the
summer
another example is the carmel river
where they would put
so much of that though those groundwater
wells were pumped to such an extent
that in the summer the carmel river
would go dry
and then there were the this was it's
the peculiarity of
california law that groundwater
uh is not managed except in certain
situations but surface water is
surface water that's what you can go out
and see that's managed and highly
regulated
groundwater it all depends on where you
are
so what happened there is that the
pumping of the groundwater and carmel
depleted the carmel river so carmel's
water supply
this you know this is california
american water
they said you got to stop pumping your
wells because
you're impacting the surface water here
and they could show the direct
connection between the two
and and for them then now they're
looking at lots of alternatives what do
you do
in monterey and pacific grove and again
it's a it's it's not going to be one
answer it's a combination of more
recycle it's a combination
of cities working together of
the stormwater capture and the desal
facility
and the desal will go um i think it's
called sand city
you know this isn't that the place just
north of uh along the coast there
but there isn't a there isn't you know
one solution
it's how do these different pieces work
and fit together
i guess i could throw in the carmel
river one
i find that's fascinating you know yeah
oh
one last thing about el carmel and the
whole salinas valley
when they put in the state water project
uh
they didn't want to be a part of it you
all know where
152 is you go over pacheco pass you know
and you get there and you see the san
luis reservoir that's
diverted water from the state water
project it's storage
we're tied into that they built a little
pipeline to take that water and put it
in the anderson reservoir south of san
jose
monterey when they were when they were
building that pipeline monterey had the
opportunity to say well do you want us
just to take a little extension and pull
it over to you guys
they said no now
we're going back to when i was in high
school okay
why did they say no
it's the same reason that marin says no
to lots of things about water
because they don't want they didn't want
urban development
more water would mean more development
and they didn't want that
or there was a fear that one would lead
to the other
so it's really interesting when you look
at the salinas valley in monterey
as a piece of the state they're really
on their own
you have all this massive plumbing that
can move water all over the state except
right in there
and i don't know to me that salinas
valley
carmel monterey sand city they're kind
of like a little microcosm for the whole
state
in a way they're throwing the carmel
river instead of the san joaquin or
sacramento
all right so it sounded like the
motivation
for a distributed treatment network was
largely
the energy cost of pumping it over
further distances
it's the energy cost and the reverse
plumbing system that's needed so
i mean it sounds like we already have a
a reasonable network
set up for distribution based on the
more centralized
um treatment um so
i guess my question is has the
has there been a consideration or study
of what the
the costs are from a financial
standpoint
and a carbon emission standpoint of
building all of these new decentralized
treatments versus
just installing you know clean energy
sources
to push the water around through the
network that we currently have
because it seems like then you could
have a more decentralized storage
network that would be a lot less
financially and um energetically
intensive process to set up so yeah
so i mean like dump trucks and all the
stuff that you need is still going to
burn a lot of carbon and
cost a lot of money to put in no that's
part of the
analysis that you do on this and when
you look at these decentralized systems
you could put
different categories here carbon
emissions
capital cost operating cost public
acceptance
and you have to step back then and say
what does the community want
what would be value to them and what
would work but so there isn't
just one simple answer to your to your
question
but it does come down to this trying to
weigh
one alternative versus another and
what's
what's politically feasible what so i
use the stanford campus as an example
we're quirky here in the water reuse
sense why are we quirky
we have two water distribution systems
on campus
right where we sit now there are two
water distributions one of them is the
water we drink it's the water that comes
from the hetchy system from the yosemite
national park
and there's another system that's lake
water from felt lake
that comes over here and it's used for
irrigation
all around everything inside the campus
drive loop
is on a its own irrigation system with
lake water
so imagine we take all of our wastewater
a million gallons a day
build this little treatment system over
here reclaim easily half that water
and put it into that irrigation system
now we don't have to use hetchy water
so but we're using that for irrigation
we're using this reclaimed water for
irrigation and we just happen to have
a separate distribution network so
why would stanford want to invest a few
million dollars
in this treatment facility it's well
it's
say well how are we going to meet our
water supply needs in the future if we
get in drought
your water gets cut back we're not going
to get any more water from the hetch
hetchy system ever
it's tapped out so our future
is like we need to sort of have
drought-proof water for the stanford
campus
and one way to that seems pretty logical
here
is to think about taking advantage of
this second distribution system
and the other one would be i live on
campus is you know extending that
over to our neighborhood they they used
to do it
a long time ago in fact i have a spigot
in my backyard where it used to come but
they cut that pipe so
i answered your question by an example
and it's uh this this idea of the
satellite treatment plant
is very attractive for the stanford
campus and the other thing is it has low
salt content too
when you get down near the bay let's say
we did do the centralized treatment
and then you put this big purple pipe up
embarcadero avenue
to the stanford campus what you'll find
over time
is because of the kind of plants we've
put here like redwoods
the water is too salty for long-term
irrigation with that
so it's the combination of the purple
pipe the energy backwards and the
higher salt
yeah question on indirect portable reuse
and recycled water um are
you talking about like gray water
systems or is this like sewage
that you're talking about recycling well
a lot of what we're talking about here
are
larger systems that would be um
of some scale now gray water when you
you know that's sort of like
shower water and that kind of thing
uh wash water that's popular at the
scale of maybe a home
and part of this idea of thinking about
decentralized systems is how
decentralized do you want to go
and gray water reuse is
something that is attractive with the
public
um it needs to be done safely
and you know and and the like but it's
something that's allowed
maybe in terms of decentralized systems
you'd probably look more at
you know new apartment buildings or a
big office complex or something like
that
or maybe you look at say the new you
know that new google not google
um apple you know the apple headquarters
that looks like a great big spaceship
well there's going to be a lot of water
there so they say well that that's a
place where you could take
all kinds of gray water and do something
with it or the same thing over with
the google campus in mountain view
so it's done and there's a lot of you
know it's done there are ways you can
you can do this and re-plumb your house
so it's at the scale of a home i
and some other folks you know always
sort of worry a little bit about the
public health consequences of it
if you the people that do it now i think
are you know
real conscious of what of what they're
doing but if you
said everyone's going to do this then
all you have to have is some
contamination in that water and
maybe you need to say well i should be
concerned about pathogens
it's not chemicals it's it'd be the
pathogens
yeah in an earlier slide you had a
uv treatment and i guess instead of
chemical treatment
to get rid of pathogens as can you say
something about
is that growing and what in what
situations is that most appropriate
well why the uv treatment there are a
few compounds
that are low molecular weight and
like to be in water and
and they're non-ionic and they can pass
through
those ro membranes and so the uv
treatment
is basically zaps those compounds
that's that's it and also it's a it's a
secondary disinfection system
but mainly it's there because it takes
care of the residual
any any chemicals that would pass
the ro membrane any organic chemicals
will be destroyed by the uv
light
all right okay
you